you guys have also penned some very
heartfelt messages about Kobe mm-hmm and
you're not only an athlete and father
husband to be your friends so how are
you doing just how you doing you know I
still can't get my my head around it
it's it's it's such a cruel thing timing
never been worse I mean 41 here's a guy
that was entering the prime of his life
gianna who I knew well Vanessa and his
whole family you know but also to
mention the other victims on the
helicopter there was nine total and
there's nine lives that are not with us
anymore
you know from a personal point of view I
was just texting with Kobe about my New
Year's party in LA he came to Jennifer's
last show we had such a quiet friendship
and and Kobe was like there was so many
he whispered in your ear he never wanted
credit he was tough as human being I've
ever met but one of the kindest and one
of the smartest and and he came on my
podcast last year and I just loved him
to death he was he was like a younger
brother and he inspired me I learned so
much for him my prayers go out for him
and Vanessa and obviously all of Laker
nation in that conversation on your
podcast he did talk about why he decided
to take helicopters did that
conversation come back to you yeah I
mean everyone started posting it again
and you know I'm such a process guy and
so was he that we were maniacal about
our work ethic and we would study each
other routines and part of his big
routine was you know going there and
back to a stable center in the chopper
because he lived in Newport Beach so I
wanted him to basically address the
listeners on how unique that approach
was because I've never heard of anyone
do that on a daily basis so he
articulated beautifully and yes so
obviously I thought back to the podcast
and I said oh my gosh when you also
mentioned that he's taught you so much
so can you give us something that he's
taught you for people that are trying to
heal that maybe are looking for a little
inspiration how to push forward through
you know Kobe wood first he was always
very inquisitive
he had a thirst for information I didn't
matter you were talking about football
basketball baseball he would ask me
about Jennifer's routines he never cared
about what happened in front of the
lights he always cared about what
happened behind the currents and he
taught me so much about you know
nutrition about lifting about being
tough about not forgetting he was a
don't forget you're a don't forget who
the f you are you're a rod and get your
hands up get your hands up I said how
Kobe you're the greatest
don't tell me he was something else and
that's it that's it I said you know a
lot of things you don't know anything
about him but he's in a better place and
he's looking over us and he would want
us to go out and have that Mambo
mentality go out and compete go out and
be a great thing and the thing that I
love the most where him and I were
connected at the heart is our girls
I saw you posted the girl dad post
can I ask you one more question about
you and Dan out here throwing at those
targets where were you throwing I have
no idea I know I thought I had a
baseball in my hand but actually was a
football push throwing like a knuckle
bar something but but talk about like
doing something with your Hiromi for
some of you guys at home and women I
mean Mickey Mantle Joe DiMaggio like Joe
Montana my guy was Dan Marino yeah and
to do that even though I'm you know over
40 now I'm still a kid at heart
I still have heroes and every day you
should wake up with you know let's go
follow your dreams he had your jersey on
that was awesome that was awesome
Italian look Joe DiMaggio in that Jersey
[Music]